[Music]
how to draw Luigi step-by-step god
dammit [ __ ] I'm so bad at drawing oh you
think you're better than drawing than me
oh okay well challenge accepted first
off before we do this I know what you're
thinking oh wow what a cool shirt you
have Felix where can i bar back why
thank you we met I to shirt pretty dope
print if you want one check out
PewDiePie high in fiber comm it's only
available for seven days so you got to
get it right away and then we're never
selling it again but definitely check
that out if you are a fan of a context
it's a good shirt if you were a fan of
context definitely recommend anyway I'm
going to be drawing with you guys today
alright join me and draw jacksepticeye
alright I'm only going to like this be
up for five seconds
okay now let's delete it and let's see
what the [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] you guys draw
I'm sure nothing it's gonna happen from
this a wow it looks just like him oh
okay that that Africa I don't know why I
don't know why I thought this would work
[Laughter]
[ __ ] for [ __ ] sake be serious my eye
aw someone reset it yeah this is great
what the [ __ ] did Arnold Schwarzenegger
come from how the [ __ ] did Arnold get in
there then I can just add a picture of
Jack that's perfect
god dammit god [ __ ] damn it great my
entire fanbase is a bunch of ADHD kid it
has 90 now been confirmed here by myself
should have deleted the tweet sooner
okay okay let's try that again everyone
let's try that again start drawing okay
woo okay this time this time for real
I'm going to delete it as soon as it's
up delete it alright it's gone surely
this time it will be a lot more relaxed
legit did no-one actually make it up we
got green everyone you draw the best you
can guide who added the Luigi
stop great great great guy confirmed
useless fanbase amazing okay this is
clearly not working let's try another
website maybe it's the platform fault
this one only a couple people should be
able to join okay we're waiting for
players i legit one actually draw him
nice
no one's guessed it yet this is so much
fun I realized now that I'm extremely
talented gotta get those hand veins in
there Oh someone got it okay well I
wasn't finished god damn it
okay someone else's turn to draw let me
get no it's a potato - [ __ ] it see what
it beholding is that a brofist
is that a [ __ ] brofist you you're
garbage you're garbage at this game
that's the worst thing I've ever seen
how has no one guessed it yet why am I
still here
you guys can't spell yes you did it
great let's try with my favorite drawing
app and see if they can do it
I see bud horseshoe for peanut or teapot
poor face I see frog or dragon or
lobster or monkey or angel I see
jacksepticeye hey guess Ted Wow wait how
to draw yank jacksepticeye step-by-step
art lesson alright this is pretty good
this seems like a good tutorial looks
cute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute are you [ __ ] kidding yes oh
good video good video okay how about
this then draw me a picture of
jacksepticeye there should be easy
Wow true talent hey there good memes hey
that's pretty [ __ ] good so I was like
in [ __ ] what 3 minutes Dan this one
is probably my all-time favorite okay
some of these are actually good I'll
give you the [ __ ] is there you know why
I take it back maybe you guys aren't so
bad at drawing after all oops I my hand
slipped
Wow now that's you know what Jack you
know what
it's come it I didn't want to do this
[ __ ] good yeah I didn't I didn't want
to do this oh ah [ __ ] [ __ ] this this is
some good [ __ ] man
my death my death ah cute now that's
just clever that's just brilliant I need
to stop with this [ __ ] fidget
goddammit someone could seriously get
hurt did you seriously go out grabbed a
potato and some grants respect respect I
have lots of and lots of respect for you
you know what I may not be good at
drawing but I'll tell you what I'm good
at Jack sucking dick no wait
Photoshop
[Music]
Thunderball forth in a solid
some owners using them ha ha
the salami in a farm owner
Oh Jack that's so sweet
you shouldn't have done that the [ __ ]
pinky that's a most [ __ ] right there boy
for real though I love you guys fanart
whenever you send it to me it always
makes me happy to see it's incredible
how talented you guys are that's just
beautiful
okay now this is quality right right
[ __ ] here this is the kind of [ __ ] I
want to see Maura
so cute hell yeah I need to bring back
that outfit for real though love you
guys so much room right check out check
out fan fibre you only got a week
there's a countdown when this fidget
spinner stops spinning you won't be able
to buy the shirt it's going to spend
pretty lunch but not that long
thank you for watching leave a like if
you enjoyed and been a pleasure as
always love you guys so much I suck it
hasn't stopped spinning yet don't worry
there's time
Brophy